es el monarca de mayor edad en ocupar el
trono a sus 73 años carlos ha esperado
mucho tiempo para ser rey ahora que por
fin ha llegado el día son muchos los
retos a los que se enfrenta el
decimotercer monarca la popularidad de
su difunta madre es uno de ellos
la reina isabel segunda una figura
querida y unificadora unió a menudo al
país durante sus siete décadas de
reinado carlos nunca ha traído el mismo
amor que su predecesor a el nuevo rey se
ha enfrentado a una serie de escándalos
a lo largo de los años su divorcio de
diana y posterior matrimonio con camila
la salida de su hijo harry de la familia
real entre otras cosas han empañado su
reputación lo mismo ocurre en el
extranjero donde la reina es una figura
muy querida entre los 56 estados
miembros de la commonwealth y para
muchos ahora que la reina ha muerto hay
pocas razones para permanecer en ella
es como dije el fin de una era en esta
nueva era será interesante ver si es tan
popular como él y eso significa que el
apoyo puede morir un poco o tal vez la
monarquía va a cambiar en ciertas formas
europeos
weiss
y ya ha hecho un tremendo trabajo y no
creo que carlos puede llevarnos a
ninguna parte y creo que es su fin
carlos sube al trono en un momento de
extrema incertidumbre en el país las
facturas de la energía siguen disparadas
y la inflación ha alcanzado su punto más
alto en 40 años la monarquía se enfrenta
desde hace tiempo a críticas por la
absorción de fondos públicos y con el
país al borde de la recesión un funeral
que costará millones de libras de los
contribuyentes no pasará desapercibido